it's snow oh my god we like barely
gotten any snow this year so far I mean
Chicago we're gonna get a lot more but
it's cool okay let me zip this up okay
well we want the exposure to be nice and
bright I'm kind of looking like evil
Krampus or something there there we go
oh my god okay so here we are Christmas
again man it's it's so good as Christmas
I'm sorry I know I do is like every year
and I don't even know if I have that may
new things to say but you know what if
every year I get to thank you guys for
watching and allowing me to do this for
a living it's worth a man I really do
have all of you to thank for you know
just your dedication your devotion and
you laugh and you love and it's every
year I got to thank you guys just so
very very much about in my heart and you
know this this year it's for many it's
been you know still kind of a tough year
for others it's been a good year but you
know a lot of people that they go
through tough times I mean that's always
one of the things you hear a lot about
on Christmas is that you know there's
good things to celebrate but there's
people that go through really tough
patches too and you know you got to try
and look out for them and you know it's
a lot about helping and giving
especially and something that there's
two things that pop in my mind this
Christmas you know Fred Rogers you know
Mister Rogers he had a saying when
something really bad is going on you
know what's your mindset how do you get
through so much tragedy and stuff and I
guess his mom always had a saying said
look to the helpers you know cuz there's
always people helping and that's very
very true and that's very very inspiring
I'll even add something else to that
whatever situation you're in you know
they say look for the helpers if you
can't find the helpers be the helper you
know be the one that actually goes and
makes change in Health's people out
because the
brings me back to a quote that my mother
used to say she said that if you're
feeling really bad on the holidays
you're feeling really really depressed
something I can help a lot is helping
someone else that really brings just a
whole new life and a whole new feeling
of value to yourself when you actually
help someone else and that's just one is
several people I mean go out there and
see see what you can do and the tiniest
things make a big difference you know
everyone kind of thinks you got to go
work at a soup kitchen or something like
that which is great which is phenomenal
there's a ton of organizations out there
that don't require a lot of effort it's
the simplest thing I can go a long way
but at the same time if you just know
someone who maybe is also going through
a rough patch maybe a similiar rough
patch maybe a rough patch you don't even
understand or identify with just
listening it can go such a long way and
you know just being there for a person
you don't always need the advice you
don't ways need the answers sometimes
you can just be an ear to lend and that
can just make a huge huge difference
without your them even knowing you but
over time it really really can make a
huge huge difference there's so many
good things you can do around the
Christmas season
and there's so many good charities you
can give to theirs there's so much I
mean I know it always looks like there's
so much bearing down on us too but
there's so much good you can do also and
you know what when there is so much
bearing down that also means there's a
lot of good you can do there's a lot of
help
you can give and in so many various ways
you know there's such a variety of help
out there it's not like there's one
thing and that's it you don't the means
there's so many means so guys just to
you I want to say thank you for
listening to me and for watching me and
for being the ear that I can you know
talk to and tell jokes to and you left
back and you keep watching and you guys
you just really are Christmas to me and
you know this feeling is so great today
and just like I say every year tried to
make it all through the year as much as
you can I know we're not gonna be able
do it every day but you know we should
be trying to put him that effort at
least just to be nice and listen and
help
and just all that great stuff and you've
definitely been that to me so once again
thank you so much have the most
fantastic holiday merry Christmas to you
all